if you guys were to really go to Skull
Island yeah which actor do you think
would most help you get out of a jam and
get out alive john c reilly actually has
a lot of like weird common sense
knowledge because of the character john
c reilly was playing he did all this
research on like how to build things and
the jungle using natural materials and
like how to dry fish and how to make
candles out of coconuts and so i feel
like he would be really helpful cuz he's
got all that information who do you
think would be your biggest ally and
staying alive goodman i would want to be
with you i feel like yeah but even
temperament yeah john jon john dunn
penny
cool under pressure you need to be cool
under pressure who do you think would
really get you out alive a genuine
helicopter yeah there you go
okay Jason
oh it's Mitchell we're really we're like
kind of trapped on islands together and
you don't know anybody except the people
that you're working with you really get
to know each other yeah maybe too much
you learn too much about your cast mate
anything you want to tell me about real
arson is an excellent organizer as a way
to kind of like bond and have fun on the
weekends I would just plan I don't know
the most ridiculous things that I could
think of karaoke go-karting laser tag
holding baby koalas you know anything
that seemed fun who's the best at
karaoke who's the worst oh I'm trying to
think about that I mean there was some
pretty pretty good classic things that
happened I mean Tom really loves that
Chumbawamba song I get knocked down so
that happened that did happen okay your
impressions your impersonations more
hilarious can you do anybody in the
Comcast oh goodness I can but I won't
look at Tom sometimes tom was running
around
or time what time would pop himself up
to do a scene we're like stan in LA okay
he's ready let's go do you all have
nicknames for each other
tea hits in my house we call him haircut
haircut Hiddleston really why is that
but I mean you've never met a dude who
looks like eat like sometime as soon as
hi super handsome I think there's a bit
of a man crush a collective man crush
going on Jason and Toby are uh you know
they're not shy of that they're both
handsome fellas and I think they know it
yeah you know they know their way around
a few things yeah it's a good group of
boys we're all gonna die together out
here coming here
[Music]
you